foreign
New York New York what's up Avery
hi Dr John what's up speaking with you
it's an honor to be speaking with you
thank you so much what are you doing
um so I have a social anxiety as well as
trust issues okay which makes it hard
for me to make friends ah
um but then I get like anxiety about the
anxiety because I start overthinking it
so I want to know like what's the
healthy approach to just like get out of
this uh vicious cycle Loop can I come in
can I go one more
so you have social anxiety so the idea
of being with people is it with crowds
or with groups or just one-on-one is all
of all the interactions just make you
anxious make you uncomfortable
yeah so groups especially but even
one-on-one in the beginning till I like
until I get comfortable with the person
okay so then you start thinking about
you start getting anxious about the
anxiety
and then
have you white knuckled it and just
tried to push on through which makes you
super awkward and off-putting and when
you finally get in the social situations
which makes everybody kind of back up a
little bit and that makes your anxiety
alarms even louder and then it just
starts looping on you
yeah that's true and also I have truck
the truck issues come up where does that
come from I
so it comes from basically my my mom has
bipolar so she was like out of the
picture when I was uh
she was like in a in a an award when I
was young like oh so she was
intentionalized okay for for your whole
childhood
so like for like two years from like I
don't know two to like four oh wow okay
and uh
my dad is like old school he's very like
tough so
okay
um
yeah so I'm gonna
in just a few minutes of time we have
here I'm gonna draw a thread it may or
may not be right but it's close enough
for what we need to do to move forward
okay
okay those years zero to four are some
of the most if not the most important
relational years of a young developing
mind and body okay
and what that little child desperately
needs is affirmation skin to skin
contact presence eye contact that is
like I see you and I'm experiencing you
from both mom and yes Dad too okay and
you didn't get that
you should have got it right and I'm
sorry that you didn't get it
trauma has been labeled the things that
happen to you
but trauma is also the things that
should have happened to you that didn't
and so I don't want you to minimize what
a huge deal it is that from two to four
your mom was in a psych ward getting the
help that she needed good for her and
you were left with a
somewhat angry somewhat militant dad who
was just probably trying to keep food on
the table and keep this household
running but there were some critical
relational needs that were missed from
for that little two and four-year-old
little little boy I just wanna I just
want to add also like my whole childhood
even like till now my my mom and dad are
like fighting you know my father my dad
says that uh he always tells us that
he's only in the relationship for the
kids sure stuff like that yeah thanks
Dad that's real helpful how old are you
now
I'm 24. okay all right so let's just
back out and so we know anxiety is an
alarm system letting us know that we're
not safe or that we're not connected
okay and it becomes Insidious when we
can't get connected because our body
sounds the alarms that connection is
going to hurt us and in your case
relationships have been a weapon your
whole life they've been painful they've
been absent they've been not what they
should have been and so your body has
identified relationships as something
that will hurt you
and yet that's the only thing that will
calm your freaking brain down is true
authentic real connection Fair are you
are you tracking with me yeah it's clear
okay yeah I
don't head on I was gonna say so I don't
want you to think you're broken your
body's actually doing a pretty good job
of taking care of you
because hey the two most important
relationships failed you
and they continue to be a mess
and so why in the world would we trust
anybody else with the inner parts of our
soul and being let's just we're going to
go ahead and label relationships as
threat and we're going to move on with
our lives
see what's happened here so your body's
actually working great it's doing
exactly what it's designed to do
identify threats and protect you from
them
okay and you recognize how
lonely
that is
and your body will avoid stress by
smoking a cigarette
it will take short-term release over
long term this is going to kill you in
the long term so your body's trying to
protect you Moment by moment but being
lonely is is a Cascade of stressors that
are going to kill you in the long term
so you gotta you gotta have to go right
through the middle of this okay
okay how would I do that okay so the
only way to heal from anxiety is to go
right in the middle of it is to walk
right through it the more you avoid it
it actually becomes a self-reinforcing
mechanism that gets stronger the more
you avoid it
so you start to go into a room full of
people your heart rate takes off on you
your thoughts spin up on you start
ruminating really really fast your hands
get sweaty and then you close the door
your body says oh sweet that's how we
keep him out of that room that's how we
keep him safe
and so the next time you try to go in
the room it's going to go even your
heart rate's gonna get up even more and
your hands are going to get even more
clammy you're going to get even more
anxious see what I'm saying because it
learns that oh that works that keeps
them out of that room and so what we
have to do is we have to retrain our
bodies that other people aren't a threat
to us
mom and dad were that happened there's a
period at the end of that sentence
now I get to choose what happens next so
let me ask you this
you you have a group of friends what's
the worst thing that could happen
you say a joke you walk into a room a
crowded room what like let's let's
imagine what's the worst thing that
could happen
and your heart rate should probably be
getting up right now like as you start
to think about it I want you to picture
it
what would happen
I guess someone would like make fun of
me or just uh what would they make fun
of you what would they make fun of you
about
I don't even it doesn't really make
sense it's just that's what I feel I
know but let's go through it what would
they make fun of you you got weird hair
no it is um I guess
they wouldn't like what I'm saying or
they would just like snub me something
like that but about what
um
whatever whatever I would say okay you
see how anxiety works it's very vague
and when you try to get down and you
start drilling into okay what is it
what's the things you would say do you
have bad politics do you have I okay
I'll tell you mine I'm super pale like a
vampire Team Edward right
um I've got my teeth aren't sparkly
white
um I used to have acne when I was a kid
so I always thought people were looking
at my teeth and looking at my skin and
looking at my like golly does that guy
ever go out into the Sun and I go out in
the sun all the time so that kept me a
little bit of a distance or I was always
awkward I would tell jokes that would be
like not that funny or they were really
really funny but kind of in a crash way
and they're only appropriate for a small
group of friends and not appropriate in
this group or I just say the weird
awkward right so I want you to drill
down with me real quick what is it what
is weird about you what would they point
out and go ah there it is what is it
foreign
I'm trying to think I guess
um I guess I let me cut to the chase
it's not it's not there yeah
your body's Chase is protecting you from
ghosts
okay
okay and you might have a political
opinion you might have an opinion on a
world issue you might have a particular
religious belief or a
um any number of things
okay and somebody
is gonna make fun of you they're gonna
ridicule you over it cool
then you're gonna your heart's gonna
still be beating
your blood's still gonna be flowing
through your body you're still gonna be
you
you're still going to be a kind
compassionate 24 year old making your
way through New York
you're still gonna have parents that
struggled your whole childhood you're
still good right it's not gonna affect
you they don't get evolved
and so right it's leaning into the facts
over those feelings those feelings are
data and then we're gonna keep going
keep on moving forward most people with
social anxiety have a picture of what
they think is gonna happen
and they have a picture of what
negatively and they have a picture of
how they're gonna feel when they finally
get those friends
and neither of those pictures pictures
are real they're distortions so if they
get around a group of people that love
them and they get home and they still
feel a little bit awkward about the
night and they start replaying some of
the conversations then they think uh
they weren't my really my friends I
don't know what I did wrong and now
they're off to the anxious world right
so right
I want you to practice a couple of
things okay
number one
every time you start to feel anxious
about friends
I want you to pause or you're about to
go to an activity you're about to go to
an event you're going to a work thing or
whatever whenever you feel it
I wanted you to pause take a big deep
breath hold it for three to five seconds
and then I want you to ask yourself this
question huh
what's my body trying to protect me from
oh okay it thinks they're gonna make fun
of me it thinks that they're gonna get
really close to me and then abandon me
for a couple of years
my body is trying to keep me from
getting loved from loving somebody again
because last time I loved
they left
right or yes I've got crooked teeth okay
yes I have acne okay yes my hair is
falling whatever the thing is that
you're worried about with your physical
appearance cool
I'm moving on
and we're going here's what we're
looking for space we're looking for a
gap
between our bodies taken off on us
trying to protect us and then that
action that thing that we're gonna do
next
and we're going to try to extend that
Gap like huh man it is getting
as I walk into this Ballroom or into
this movie theater with a friend or as I
go out on this first date I can
literally feel it
and then when I sit down with that
person I'm gonna say man First Dates
make me anxious
I'm gonna go ahead and just put it on
out there
or I am super weird on first dates I'm
sorry
I'm way better at the date two and three
do you see what I'm saying I'm gonna go
ahead and take the bullets out of my own
anxieties gun so it can't shoot him at
me anymore it's got nothing left
because I am with a group of guys yep
like what would be the what would be the
well so I would take that those deep
breaths and then what would I what would
I say ask yourself why am I nervous
around these guys do I feel less than
them
do they have bigger muscles than me are
they are they more making more money
than me do they have nicer cars or
apartments than me like what what am I
what why is my body responding as though
I'm not safe I'm in danger
I'm inferior
ask yourself those questions and I have
radically different political beliefs
than my best friends on the world we're
different on almost every metric and we
Razz each other and we give each other a
hard time about it and we make fun of
each other like the whole thing and
there's times that I've left angry and
they've left angry and then we just get
back together the next week or the week
after that
but there's a very few people in my life
that get a vote and the rest of people
don't and if you can't be fully you
around this group of guys cool man
they're just not going to be your gang
they're not going to be for you
does that make sense
what you have to do for the first time
in your life is practice feeling safe
okay
okay and
so so so I just want to recap what
you're saying basically you're telling
me that I should take those deep breaths
think about what do these guys have over
me like why am I not why am I less than
them no no no you're not less than them
why does your body respond as though you
are what is your body trying to protect
you from with these guys this has
nothing to do with them this has
everything to do with you why is my body
trying to protect me
and then there's going to be sometimes
when your body's like I gotta go home
cool
that alarm's got real loud hey guys I'm
gonna go and cut out tonight I'll see
you later I do that with some regularity
I've got an I've got a deep history with
anxiety and when I do that then I ask
man those alarms were loud tonight what
is that about most often in my life it's
because I haven't been taking care of my
body I haven't been sleeping I haven't
been eating right I haven't been I've
gotten behind at work I've got laundry
piles everywhere I've created a chaotic
environment for myself so I asked myself
why the alarms are so loud
see what I'm saying and every once in a
while I gotta cut out I just cut out
early and you know what my friends who
love me they don't care they're gonna
give me a hard time about it because
they're my friends but that's fine
and the people are like oh my gosh
you're going to bed you're already
leaving what a loser well we're not
gonna be friends so have a good one you
don't need to have a good one and I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna lose a second of
sleep over their opinion because their
opinion doesn't matter to me
you see what I'm saying
yeah you aren't broken my brother you
just have to learn a new set of skills
and that is how do I be in the presence
of relationship and by the way don't use
a group of guys
like I've got to go make friends I gotta
go make friends you got to be my friend
that is a recipe for you feeling anxious
and they become a tool that you are
using to make yourself feel better and
everybody can feel that
be with people because you're worth
being around
be with people because you want to enjoy
people's company and you want to
have good times with people and share
misery with one another
so I should start with like one-on-one
that's totally up to you man
there's not a right or wrong way to do
it what we're doing whether it's
one-on-one okay dude let's go hang out
um take the pressure off this hey uh Hey
guys let's we're all going to the movies
let's go catch a concert let's go do
whatever let's go down and go bowling or
whatever the thing is I don't know what
y'all do in New York
um
let's go do those things and then yeah
I'm gonna go and by the way
almost every time I'm heading out to go
somewhere my body tells me you don't
want to do this
we had a flag football game the other
day dude I won I sat in my car for 20
minutes before I walked outside
it was so fun
by the time it was over but I felt the
alarms and my body's trying to avoid
this thing I am gonna do it and I'm
gonna choose to go out and have a
positive attitude about it and I did it
was a blast and this is 10 or 15 years
of me working through this Avery so this
isn't something that's going to happen
overnight
but find a friend go hang out go just go
get coffee be like hey what's going on
how's your life
um I'm going to send you the questions
for humans I'm gonna send you guys night
I'm gonna send you a dating pack and I'm
going to send you uh friends so you can
if if there's just a group of dudes
y'all are hanging out you can pull these
things out and your friends are gonna
give you a hard time guys if you if you
pass if you pull out the questions for
humans guys night they're gonna make fun
of you that's fine
that's fine
um if you have mixed couples great
if you're out dating you're like all
right I'm not great at first date so I
got these cards great and if that
person's like oh my gosh what a loser I
don't want to be around you then you've
just saved yourself months of months of
Heartache on the front end because this
is it's not gonna end well right if
someone's gonna just prejudge you that
way but whether it's one person whether
it's a bunch here's what we're doing
we're asking our bodies why are you
trying to take care of us and we're
creating space just a gap between our
body feeling it and then boom we are off
to the races when my thoughts start
going down I can't believe I said that
that was so stupid no no no no no no
I'm not gonna have this conversation it
was a dumb joke I'm moving on with my
life
and we're gonna slowly retrain our
bodies to take control of our thoughts
and of our actions and to let our bodies
know that relationships yeah they can
hurt us
so the only way
to peace and safety thanks for calling
my brother